is we we have more power yeah we have we  so so if we are going to get more power  it comes with responsibility having more  of the responsibility because the men  the men have one choice condom or no  condom we can we can we know when we're  ovulating you know when you're you  should oh yeah you can't wait wait and  you you are the choice you get who gets  to chew who all right all right wait who  gets to choose whether or not they're on  birth control men or women women who  gets to choose whether or not we take  the plan B men or women women who gets  to choose when if if you have sex on or  off your when you're ovulating men or  women who has the choice to track their  cycle men or women women who has the  choice to get an abortion women women  okay so that's that's the point